[音楽]
[拍手]
1年前僕たちは渋谷のマックで出会いその1カ月後にはた今その1カ月後にはアン村西
何便キャンペーンと足を飛びました
僕たち2人は今映像生産としています
今まで僕たちはバングラディシュでフィギュアを舐め見合う
そしてアメリカでは副腎さん2
のドキュメンタリーそしてきれい人では6畳で暮らす孤児とそれを育てフォームメスの
ドキュメンタリーなど世界はフォグでドキュメンタリーを追っています
また日本国内でも様々なドキュメンタリーに触れさせていただいて
今では nhk さんまたは約3などとして映像
僕僕は1年前カメラさえ持っていません
して1年前始めた時にはジャーナリズムの柱の陰
知らないようなは家族のですが
今ではさっ
たような大きな鉢と仕事をさせていただいたりあるいは
描く受光部したりそしてペットなんか持っていただいて足も生きております
僕たちがこの一年で
どのようにして別も楽大きなパワーを持って自分たちの活動を促進してきたのか
そのことを今日お話したいっ
曲間的にその音源お湯すればそれは僕たちが
生かされていると言う
そして感謝をすることを覚えたからです
皆さんの中には
表なんか頑張れないなった
頑張りたいけどわからん
連絡せーなーとか
頑張っているけど結果が見えないん
そうした人も
家と思います
で僕たちもそういう人たちでした
だからこそ今日は皆さんに何かを考えるきっかけようってい
とはいっても僕はそんなことができるような人間ではありませんでした
学生時代はやる気もなく
小さい高はおもしれー
あらゆる国に対して消極的
そんな人間だったんです
でもある日たまたま僕はカメラに出会って
それがきっかけでたくさん入ってましたん
その中で彼にも出会って今の活動に言ってやりました
そしてパラ第一年というスピードでいろいろなしょういただいたり
をして喋らせていただきたい
さまざまな機会をいただいて
ものすごいスピードですっ
それがなずなぜできた
っていうのをないでいつも考えてです話すときに
誰が出すと daigo
3の前のことに感謝をしての前にやるべきこと
100%でぶつかっていった
ただこれだけです
このシンプルなことができたからこそ僕たちは
までたくさんの人によれば
水力のことが
ただこうは言うけれども
僕は本当にそんな人間ではなかったんです
今こうして僕はに兄弟を卒業して方向なんです
も事でこんなに素晴らしいあるじゃない
申し訳ないんですけど
ジャイアン不正の時
大学でちゃめちゃたーぼきましたいっ
ジャメちゃった思っています
履修登録すらみんなに治っています
ベスト8台もギリギリまで勉強しないです
ギリギリになっていつも頭の人にという作詞て
思います
優雅おります
コーヒー持っていきますが入って
いつもそうやってみせてもらって行った
それはなぜかというと
めんどくさい事がないです
年度サイプができるよくにいる
ですねっ大
そんなに家なんだってなるかもしれないんです
皆さんにもそれぞれそういう順番はある
念仏再建が好きな
方ないと思います
みんな粘土細工を先延ばしにしたしそういう部分でて少なからず皆がある
それはこんなことを言っている今でも私
会議もそういう瞬間はそれあ
えっ
ています
みんなある
でも僕たちが自信を持って一つ
それは
僕た実際は今してこの活動に対しては一瞬たりとも
けど
一周タイプもその瞬間があった
それができたのは何です
って考えたときにある beats
pass あれば
リネな民ラップでの経験月
もの軽減が僕たちを聞くられて今僕たちをここまで運んできた大きな
言語位
思います
ちなみに部品花壇整備
知っているバタッ
シャーパしますありがとうございます
でも今じゃないと思っ
まあ品等が切れないので出る
その子をパス車動画を
持ってきましたなので
だ言って少しだけ定番封印でなります
でやら下皿じゃその頃まで入って歩けそのてみただけ
前でそのちゃんっ
ああああまあで&五輪
アーバン6の日
[音楽]
7バルーンである覚えてはある意味で r 通り生まれあるのである恐怖が
r ドレッドロマーノが東大文丸色を作るマトラうんっ
ブルーゲイル生まれる流れですからガラコレっ
[音楽]
ろーいんやは
山というふうにで
ダーツを受け
陰謀のバングラデシュに今見えています
彼らは家まで
父親が目の前で付与され
そして母親や娘は家族のでお会いできされ安倍は火の海に投げられ
そのような命からがらいい国のバブルでしに彼はを踊って
100万人以上の人達は
そして家の先でもテロリスト扱いされたり
仕事もなく十分4
い
そうした生活を余儀なくされる
そんなはあれだけであっ
そしてその場所に行って僕たちを取材して
このような感想というかこのようなところで自分を感じたことを表現するのはすごく
安直に統一しまうします
ただ
ポジショントークみたいなことはしたくないし
のアレももちろん色々と話す期待は大
なんとなく
アっぽいことはやっぱり難しいこれそれなりのことを言うんじゃない
共和制
オフトの世代ですけど1
対応ができるといいですね
素直に自分の感情に
素直でありたい
重い
しても理解いうと僕があれらと出会って
感じたことそれは
あ
これがあって
生まれている
命て働いていっ
本来に戻って
非正規的に生きている
そしてそこに感謝を思います
を旅は
青春してか
それでなるん
で皆さんという家
水性生きて
家に帰っています
はいを
みんなで自転車でだ
みたいでした合わせん
本を
あのー幹部がは嫌だと思う結成しちゃいます
んだけど
僕がはが歴史には彼らわー
奥華子がやっていたように政府猫の指導を変えたり
2月して描い行われたり
自分のタイニー
食べて
もやし部だったり
そういうこと最後にいいね
尾辻今まで部品やりがいも
作曲いった p ピンで
抑えの総文を持っそうね
質問少年は容姿ですね
オウムですねそう
そんな二人のドキュメンタリーを持っていました
あるいは誠実は6がで
母親は
ブラックのバイバイ
ゲーム手に入れられ
シュシュ兄へ
あるいは
ギャルズ出動を殺して
自分はラッパーとして
人生を
かけているけど黒人差別し女性差別の字まで
うれしい
そんなそれもドキュメンタリーを送っていた
いろいろ等僕たちはあまざまな人だって
さまざまな場所に行く中で
ボンボンボン丼
自分たちは
生かされている
そしてそこに本校が家で
反射もできるなりました
しこんなことを
ここまで伝えても
触り切らないことは jj 所
それは僕たちもすーっ
音ズレ相撲や
いいかされた
感謝
そんなにしてやっ
を前に知ってるよ
らみんな僕たち彼にもうと思ったらそれは本当の意味では変わってないっていうのも
合計剣風して分かります
歴史の教科書
お母さん言われだよああ
部から有名なサッカー選手が水通ししてなら同じだろうか
聞いたことがあるでも音符の意義であなたを理解すること
難しいそれでも
僕たちこの1アウトしてポン酢に大丈夫ぶー
し僕たちの活動を支えてきた大事なところ
この
ように話をさせていただき
皆さんは
今日なぜ織り込まれている
思いません
は軽い
9あるいい
ある皆さんこの中にそれぞれ
第を持っていると思うんです
を
担任8木カメさんの解雇エネルギーは
さっきあるいは今日傘
色の夜いる mother
ご飯はなかった
それそう
をから
もっと大学いえば
皆さんは
今日行きたいと願った
れたらいいの超
ただ位
だから
を起用してい
そして足お菓子舗に来て
僕は言葉は知っ
みんなそれを
面白い効果はわからないしもしかしたら面白いと思う
アメリオ
何かを感じて
みんなは付
道
綺麗な夕日差額を照らされながら
銀色のにある感じてはいる
私は
ください
俺の立ち位置を週5
自分たちが他にして今されていて
描いたに測って
すごい感謝するということ
僕たちの
義務で
し同時に力であるとフォーク調
います
はたちは
本当に僅かに行ったみたいに今まで絵を塗って
いけません
う過ぎ去っていく1秒1秒本当に全力で
浮きあっ
エアーすべての人で
擦れるの人と本当に本気 f 作品しっ
だからこそ僕たちは
チェーンで法案成長してくれ
送信
も体は僕たちは代謝言えないです
あれもしかしつ多くになるカウに全然大使になって
実際にカメラも
j 1カメラ
使い方もはからっ
別にーなくくれついもしゃべる2ができるか
スキルがですねバターを入れないし
言えば僕はラグいうタイプ
それぐらい
別に何か一人で綺麗じゃなかっ
だけど
僕がここまで来れたらやっぱり多くの人の支えがあったか
多くの人に協力してもらって
彼もそうだけど
僕みたいな人間じっしょんやろ収入があります
応援してくれなかったら毎に行うと小沢氏は彼らのこれ
なにそれか登ったかというとそれは
オークたちが全力だからっ
僕たちが支えてくれてるみんなに感謝が入ったからを
人はわかる方
本質が本当に全力か
この人に自分の父の人生一瞬オスカーハチュある
それじゃないっ
すごい
だけど少なからずようで
が変わらしていく
傘わけで
きても楽しているのは
僕たちが全力やってロスシェ
家がに感謝しているを観測
イブでもはいい
皆さんの人生を今まで以上に美しく
ようって言っても
今日から右
僕は
今生かされています
感じて
反射数
を
感謝は者等ですお前が9分
[拍手]